the Game of Thrones Season seven finale
begins with Daenerys Asami arriving at
King's Landing this is as close as Dany
has ever come to a goal of the Iron
Throne she could broadly swoop in and
take it now but she's holding off in the
hopes of a truce in a vision in season
two Dany
approaches the throne and reaches for it
but doesn't take it
maybe this suggests that Dany will never
win the throne Jaime and Bronn watch
from above and talk about the meaning of
life
is it gold family Cox bran is one of the
only characters inference who's actually
better off now than he was in season 1
he's made money being knighted got
people calling him my lord while so many
others have lost loved ones or lost
their heads or their hands or their
[ __ ] Jon Snow also arrives at King's
Landing when his uncle Ned came to this
city
he died when Ned's father and brother
came to this city they died too the
Starks are never comfortable in the
crowded capital Jamie once said that
Starks are made of ice and when they
come south they melt but as we soon
learn John is more than just a stark the
group's meet in the ruins of the dragon
pit the dragon pit was built a few
hundred years ago as a sort of a stable
for the Targaryen dragons but as
Daenerys learned in marine dragons don't
like captivity over the years the pit
dragons grew smaller and stunted which
reflects the slow decline of the
Targaryen dynasty it also reflects the
nature of magic and Game of Thrones
magic is wild and uncontrollable a sword
with no hilt if you lock a dragon in a
box it'll waste away but if you let it
loose it'll eat people so there's no
safe way to use it which is why some
people think that the maesters of the
citadel may have deliberately killed off
the dragons as part of a conspiracy
against magic go watch that video but
everyone comes together in the biggest
meeting of characters ever Tyrion
reunites with bran and pod who have both
saved his life in the past Brienne and
the Hound talk about aya like proud
soccer moms even though Brienne almost
killed Sandor once other reunion
son so happy Tyrion says his sister
Cersei after he killed their father
Tywin
Daenerys meets Jaime who killed her
father Aerys Theon says you Ron who
captured his sister Yara and Jon mate
Cersei who helped kill his uncle Ned
there's also this awkward love square
between Brienne Jaime Cersei and Euron
so all of this history makes for a very
tense scene bran leaves early with pod
Tyrion had just offered Bronn gold if he
changes sides and bran always said he
looks after himself and doesn't want to
risk his life fighting dragons so it
looks likely that bran will leave Cersei
and maybe join Daenerys but another
possible reason why bran leaves is that
there's apparently drama between bronze
actor and says he's actress and they
don't want to be in the same scenes the
helm threatens the mountain which Alba
confirms cleganebowl the idea that these
brothers will fight to the death and the
greatest grudge match in Westeros Sandor
has always wanted to kill his brother
they fought once in season one and it
looks like they'll fight a final time in
season 8
since Gregor is now some kind of zombie
the Hound might need to use fire to kill
him which might allow Sandor to get over
his fear of fire which he got from
Gregor burning his face in the first
place
so cleganebowl is gonna silly but it
could give a neat sense of closure to
Sandhills story
Daenerys arrives on her dragon you can
tell she's been practicing her
impressive entrances and Euron gets a
hungry look seeing the dragon there's a
whole plot in the books about Euron
trying to use a magic horn to steal one
of Danny's dragons maybe he'll try
something similar in the show Dany
apologizes for arriving late and making
everyone wait which is a bit of a meta
joke about the fact it's taken Dany
seven seasons to join the main plot in
Westeros
Tyrion starts a speech but Euron
interrupts and gets all aggressive and
threatens to kill Yara but Cersei
shushes him
Cersei might have actually told you
wrong to do this because it's useful to
remind down inside that Cersei has a
hostage but shushing neurons threat also
makes Cersei look cooperative it's kind
of the opposite of how Littlefinger uses
Lynn Corbray in book 4 for those
keeping score John shows everyone the
zombie which is the first time most of
these people have seen a white Tyrion
Varys miss and I thean Brienne Jaime
Cersei
they've all been mostly separate from
the supernatural in this story but now
magic and politics come crashing
together John explains the threat of the
army of the Dead with Qyburn it's love
at first sight but everyone else is
suitably spooked
Euron says he'll retreat to the Iron
Islands which is a lie designed by
Cersei to make Dany think Euron's out of
the picture when he's actually getting
more soldiers for Cersei Cersei says
she's convinced and agrees to a peace on
one condition
john has to swear to stay out of the war
between Cersei and Dany
so this is a good strategy from Cersei
she's hoping to take away Danny's
greatest ally and let Danny fight the
dead while Cersei gathers a strength to
later fight a weakened Danny but Jon
refuses Circe's deal and says he stomps
out
Brienne tries to get Jaime to change
Susie's mind telling him [ __ ] loyalty
which is a neat reversal of their usual
dynamic with earth keeping Brienne
trying to teach honor to Jaime the
Kingslayer but the job of convincing
Cersei Falls to the man who says he
hates most her brother Tyrion Cersei
starts out hating Tyrion for a lot of
the same reasons their father Tywin
hated Tyrion for the death of Tyrians
mother in childbirth and fatir Ian's
mockery of their family pride but
Circe's hatred of Tyrion grows through
the series as he undermines her power
threatens her and her children and sends
marcela to Dorne in season 4 so she
accuses Tyrion of killing Joffrey which
she didn't but then he kills Tywin and
ever since says he's tried to have
Tyrion killed says he accuses him of
wanting to destroy their family even
though Cersei has killed more Lannisters
than Tyrion has she blew up uncle Kevan
and cousin Lancel it's true that the
murder of Tywin was a huge blow to House
Lannister but at least in the beginning
it wasn't Tyrians goal to destroy his
family he loved Jaime and he loved Miss
Ella and Tommen and deep down Cersei
must know this because when Tyrion tells
her to kill him she doesn't maybe she
only wants to keep
Eliab to make this peace deal but Cersei
says she doesn't care about the world
doesn't care about anyone but herself
and the people she loves
Tyrion works out that she's pregnant the
same ends and then they make the peace
deal so we don't know exactly what
happens here but it seems so she uses
her pregnancy to show that she's got
something to lose to make Cersei more
believable when she says she'll make
peace it's similar to when Cersei used a
pregnancy to assure Jaime's loyalty
she's using her body as a strategic tool
as Cersei once said a woman's weapon is
between her legs as always Cersei uses a
weapon to protect her power and her
pride some people think that Tyrion
might have offered Cersei something to
convince her to make peace Malak maybe
that her child would be the heir to the
throne or something but does Cersei have
much leverage in this situation anyway
it's in her interests to make peace even
if she gets nothing in return so there
may not have been a secret deal here
between Cersei and Tyrion at the dragon
pit Danny tells John that marry master
said that Dany can't have children and
John suggests that Miri might have been
wrong they keep on bringing up Danny's
fertility maybe she can have kids now
maybe she always could and Daario was
just shooting blanks it could solve this
whole succession problem if daddy has a
kid with John and a pregnancy could also
suggest that Dany might actually survive
this series at least for another nine
months so she declares that she'll make
peace with Dany and fight with her
against the dead but later we learned it
was all a lie and says he will let Danny
go north while she stays south and
gathers her strength Jaime argues that
they need to go help defeat the dead and
that they won't defeat Dany in the long
run anyway
Cersei points out that Dany has lost a
dragon which means that she can be bait
and she reveals that she sent Euron to
Essos to hire a mercenary group called
the golden company using the gold from
Highgarden in the books the golden
company has a long history and they're
involved in varus's complex conspiracy
go watch that video that sort of stuff
won't be in the show but they do have
Olly fonts so that'll be dope point is
with the help of the golden company so
she hopes to defeat Dany when she
returns from fighting the dead but
Jamie's mad he's mad that Cersei didn't
tell him her plan he's mad that she's
talking about marrying Euron and most of
all he's mad about being forced to break
his word to help Danny cuz all his life
Jaime's been hated for killing the king
he swore to protect Aerys Targaryen
now Jamie wants to ride with Aries his
daughter and restore his honor do
something selfless for once Jamie stood
by Cersei when she tried to kill his
brother Tyrion he stood by her when she
killed Jamie's uncle and cousin and
hundreds of innocents but now Jaime
realizes he can't be with Cersei and
become the person he wants to be and so
he leaves Jaime rides north instead of
rich gold Lannister armor he wears black
and rides a black horse maybe hinting he
could join the Nights Watch someday but
Jamie's final fate may be back at the
capital he and Cersei often say that
they'll die together
watch the Cersei video to see how that
might end as Jaime rides snow falls on
King's Landing winter is here up at
Winterfell Littlefinger leads Sansa to
believe that IO wants to kill Sansa and
become Lady of Winterfell
which are you herself Connie hinted last
episode and Sansa seems to believe Peter
but later she teams up with Arya and
turns against him so what changed some
people think that Sansa and Arya had
been secretly working together all along
that these arguments they had lost
episode was staged under the assumption
that Littlefinger would spy on them so
he would think he's plan to divide the
sisters was working while they actually
plotted against him but this idea isn't
really supported by the show it's not
clear what Sansa would gain by leading
Peter along there's no evidence that
Peter would have heard these multiple
private conversations and if Peter was a
good enough spy to see these wouldn't he
have also heard their real plans an
interview with brands actor suggests
that they censor aiya scenes were real
but at some later point Sansa asked bran
for help and he told her that
Littlefinger misled them and only then
did Santa team up with aya against Peter
so there was no complex hidden plot the
Starks were just really slow to work out
that Littlefinger was playing
them even though Sansa already knew
little fingers been playing her and even
though I as a highly trained spy and
lie-detector and even though brand knows
everything so this whole plot was a
pretty huge fail from the stark siblings
but they now realized that Peeta is
their enemy and accuse him of his crimes
killing Lysa conspiring to kill Jon
Arryn lying about this dagger to cause
war betraying Ned and giving Sansa to
the Bolton's Littlefinger falls to
pieces and totally fails to defend
himself even though he probably could
the Starks have no hard evidence of
Peters crimes apart from the word of a
crippled boy who claims to be psychic
surely the master schemer Peter could
talk his way out of this just like he
talked his way out of Lices murder in
the first place but he breaks down when
he sees Sansa said against him he loves
her so much in his own creepy way that
he just cannot deal with her against him
and so he's killed by aya with the same
blade Peter used to start this old war
in season one Catelyn once said that
Peter is clever but not wise he was
clever enough to trick Sansa and Arya
clever enough to cause a whole war but
not wise enough to see that his
obsession with Sansa was his blind spot
and his downfall and now Sansa has
finally freed herself of his control all
series she's been a pawn of Cersei the
Tyrells Peter Ramsay
but as Peter says even the humblest
basis can have wills of their own Sansa
has learned from the people who
controlled her and freed herself at last
she's her own person now with her own
power we'll see next season how she
chooses to use it we also get a scene of
ire and Sansa being friends again
Sansa quotes Ned saying when the snows
fall and the white winds blow the lone
wolf dies but the pack survives Stark's
got a stick together might have been
better advice if Ned said hey if you're
thinking of murdering your sister ask
your psychic brother first to check if
you're being little fingered but it did
work out in the end the Starks are
united at Dragonstone
Theon tells John about how he felt
growing up at Winterfell
he felt torn between his Greyjoy
identity
and wanting to be a part of the stark
family and that conflict led Theon to
commit his crimes betraying the Starks
capturing Winterfell killing Roderick
killing innocent kids he has suffered
for his crimes Ramsay saw to that and
he's tried to redeem himself by saving
Sansa but he still feels guilt and feels
torn between Greyjoy and Stark
so Jon gives Theon the forgiveness and
the acceptance that he needs says that
Theon can be both a Greyjoy and a Stark
so with his character conflict fixed by
a back way no los dos a Theon sets off
to save his sister Yara but first he has
to win over his Ironborn crew and he
does it the way Ironborn do the violence
on the one hand it might feel kind of
cheap for Theon's long and complex
character arc to climax with a fistfight
but on the other hand this scene really
does capture the meaning of Theon's
Greyjoy identity he gets beaten down and
defeated but then he rises again harder
and stronger no matter how bad he
suffered how bad he [ __ ] up he can
survive and persist and succeed after
the fight Theon baptizes himself with
salt water born again like he was in
season two but this new identity he's
forged is stronger than before he
gathers his 20 good men and sets off to
save his sister Sam arrives at
Winterfell and meets with bran who he
helped through the wall back in season 3
bran says he remembers everything and he
confirms the biggest oldest secret in
Game of Thrones
that Jon Snow is the child of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark Rhaegar is
Daenerys brother and Lyanna is Ned's
sister 20 years before the main story
Rhaegar ran off with Liana even though
Rhaegar was married to Elia Martell and
Liana was promised to marry Robert
Baratheon so Robert started a war
against the Targaryen Skilling Rhaegar a
serpent King Aerys and making himself
King Liana died giving birth in Dorne
and Ned Stark came home with baby Jon
Snow and claims Jon was his bastard in
order to protect John because Robert
would have killed him if he knew he was
the son of a Targaryen so that's the R +
L equals J theory and
readers have known about this for years
but Sam says something that not even
brand-new that raiga annulled his
marriage to Elia Martell and secretly
married Liana meaning that John is not a
bastard but a legitimate child of Prince
Rhaegar which means John's the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne ahead of
Daenerys a lot of readers suspected this
- there are heaps of hints in the books
that John would be king and people have
speculated for years about a secret
marriage one idea was that they would be
married on the Isle of faces because
that's near where Liana met Rhaegar and
it has a bunch of weirwood trees where
words are used in northern marriage
ceremonies and greenseers like bran can
see through words for their visions so
maybe this will be how we learn of the
marriage in the books but this idea of
annulment raises questions in the books
it seems as though you can only annul a
marriage if it's unconsummated if the
husband and wife haven't had sex Rhaegar
and Elia had two kids
so could their marriage be annulled
maybe in the books Rhaegar will just
marry Liana in addition to Elia the
Targaryen do have a history of polygamy
but another weird twist is that Jon
Snow's real name is apparently Akon
Targaryen Aegon is a popular name
because it's the name of the Conqueror
who first took over Westeros and founded
the Targaryen dynasty but the weird
thing is that one of Regas other
children by his first wife Elia is also
named Aegon so Rhaegar three children
unnamed Rainey's Aegon and Aegon why one
possible reason is that Rhaegar seemed
to be naming his children after Aegon
the Conqueror and his two sisters
Rhaenys and Visenya Rhaegar was really
into prophecy and thought his first son
aegon would be azor Ahai maybe with his
two other children Rhaenys and Visenya
forming the three heads of the Dragon
another prophetic thing point is he
might have expected his child with Liana
to be a daughter and to name her Visenya
but when Rhaegar died and Jon turned out
to be male Liana would have to come up
with a new name and by that time reyga's
first son aegon was dead so Liana might
as well name this new kid Aegon for the
Conqueror and maybe to commemorate the
dead Aegon but it might still be a
different name in the books
some people think John will
be called a Mon as a parallel to John's
mentor and ancestor Maester Aemon
or maybe Joe Harris one of the better
Targaryen Kings whose name starts with
the same letter as John but they say a
blue inter rose by any other name still
smells as sweet
so maybe the name is unimportant what
matters is that John is half stark
and half Targaryen which connects nicely
to what John told Theon earlier that
just as Theon can be a stark and a
Greyjoy John can be a stark and a
Targaryen we also get our first glimpse
of John's father Rhaegar Targaryen he's
perhaps not as pretty as he's described
in the books but he does look a lot like
his brother Viserys maybe Viserys was
imitating his brothers look Brown
explains the Rhaegar and Lyanna were in
love
Rhaegar didn't kidnap and rape er like
Robert Baratheon claimed and so brand
says Robert's rebellion was based on a
lie which might not be strictly true
Rhaegar and Lyanna weren't the only
cause of the war you could argue it
really began when King Aerys killed
Ricard and Brandon stark and demanded
the heads of Robert and Ned but still
this misunderstanding adds tragedy to
Liana
and radars relationship star-crossed
lovers from opposing houses who both
died young but before we get to rosy
eyed about it remember we still know
almost nothing about Liana and elyes
perspectives here it sure looks like
Elia was screwed over by a husband
Rhaegar and that Liana was a teenager
hooray gonna tell and used to produce a
prophecy baby so in the books at least
there's still a lot to be explored about
these relationships while John's cousin
bran explains John's parents John has
sex with his aunt
Daenerys which is a whole lot of weird
layers of incest tyrion listens outside
and looks concerned he might be a bit
jealous of John everyone's kind of in
love with Daenerys but he might also
worry that romance between Danny and
John could complicate the political
situation as a mon once said what is
honor compared to a woman's love if
you're in love with someone you might
make decisions based on what's best for
them instead of what's best for the
kingdom in book 5 Barisan thinks of all
the love
throughout history that have caused
conflict including Rhaegar and Lyanna
'he's so maybe tyrion sees that john and
Danny's relationship could be
destructive
but as Rhaegar knew he can't fulfill a
prophecy of ice and fire to save the
world without breaking a few eggs at
East watched Ormond and barek chill on
the wall when the night King arrives
with his army and with his dragon
Vissarion breathes blue fire on the icy
wall and it starts to crack the wall has
stood for some 8,000 years built by the
first men children and Giants to protect
the living from the dead it's one of the
hinges over the world in book 1 John
thinks if the wall Falls the world Falls
with it and now the wall Falls there is
nothing between the army of the Dead and
Westeros the fact that the night king
uses Vasari on to take down the wall
supports the idea that the lake scene
last episode was a trap to take Danny's
dragons because otherwise the night king
was marching on east watch with no
apparent plan to pass the wall so maybe
the night king like bran is some kind of
green seer who can have visions of the
future and past his power must be
limited he'd win all the time if he knew
everything but this definitely makes the
night king even more dangerous some
people think that bran and the night
king are the same person like that bran
went back in time and walked into this
guy who became the night king and lived
as a white Walker for thousands of years
and is now battling the past version of
himself which might help explain the
psychic connection between the two it's
a fun idea but there's no real evidence
and it would require a level of
time-travel [ __ ] that might not
really fit the story of Thrones as we
know it so it's a cool idea but it
doesn't seem likely finally some people
are worried the barrack and torment
might have died here but it looks like
they run to safety along the wall
barracks been talking about destiny so
much that there's no way he's dying off
screen and Tolman's got to survive to
make giant blond babies with Brienne
right so they'll probably be back in
season 8 but who else will Game of
Thrones Season 7 killed the phrase the
sand snakes the tarly's 11
Thorin's benjin and Littlefinger so
basically all the lords of the south are
dead along with some other loose ends
this lets season eight focus on the main
conflicts further north between Cersei
and Daenerys and between the living and
the dead
almost all the named characters are in
the north or heading there the Starks
Sansa I are in bran the northern Lords
Lac Liana Brienne and Podrick Sam and
Gilly divorce kendry and the Hound
dolorous EDD with the Nights Watch
berrak and torment at east watch and
Danny's crew Tyrion Varys Jorah mass and
a grey worm with the unsullied and the
Dothraki Jamie and probably brought all
his left south with Cersei is Qyburn and
the mountain Euron's heading to Essos to
get the golden company with the help of
the iron bank and Theon's out to save
Yara who might be at the Iron Islands
with Iran or traveling with you Ron
maybe and Melisandre is in volantis
maybe with some other red priests she
said that she had returned there are
others who we might see again there's
mirror in the neck the maesters at Old
Town and Robin Arryn who rules the Vale
represented in the north by bronze Ian
Royce we don't know what's happening in
the Riverlands but maybe we'll see ed
Muir again the reach Stormlands and
Dorne a big question mark maybe absurd
you take them all back while Danny's
gone we probably won't say ilaria or
Daario or Illyria or Quaithe we'll
hopefully see ghosts
but this basically comes down to is all
these people in the north against the
dead and against Queen Cersei the time
is done for complicated politics for
whole episodes devoted to walking and
talking the show has just six episodes
left to give satisfying ends to all
these character arcs to answer big
mysteries like azor Ahai to decide who
live and who'll die and to bring an end
to the Song of Ice and Fire
thanks for watching this video and this
series alt shift X is now taking a break
the patreon is paused but we will be
back with more videos analyzing the game
of Thrones books and show we can also do
other series you aren't Westworld
stranger things
American Gods comment below what you
want to see there might also be a kind
of book club livestream podcast type
thing coming and there is also the
season finale of old schwifty exon soon
though that's honestly best avoided but
yeah lots more coming from old chief
decks in the near future thank you to
everyone who helps make the Thrones
community great go check out Radio
Westeros history of Westeros the
subreddits podcast youtubers Twitter as
tumblr rights translators the artists
among attached alternans haruki sake
everyone there is heaps of great content
out there some links are below
finally thank you to the patrons
including vine yo Dawg Cameron Weiss
reverence andrea miriam essa michael
Appel jason Rattray alex go candle ryan
steel eric louis-dreyfus that stevie
franchise triangle wine company ab3
harry I love mondays Neil chop de Caro
and CK fred petty like craft miniature
studios David how Matthew Elijah
Williams Jake Bolin Chris Amos Chris
Cole Craig Reilly Bobby eels Patrick
Lawrence Coghlan hang clear Oh Clayton
Anton Zeck Gordon Gina penny Keira
shadow Valentin dig and disco Dan Jessie
deal Hellas oyster rig a Homburg
Stephanie Morris Brandon Winslow advil
ansiana shiera seastar
a leopa Lou Cardinale doomsday katha
Ernest and everyone else who supports
alt shift X Cheers
you